for a long time we always expected
people to just receive the goods that we
make and you know where there was no
conversation really I mean oh the entire
communication between business and the
public was you know the advertising
campaign you know 30-second ads but
that's radically changed there is this
ongoing dialogue between the public and
and and people using products or you
know being in those experiences and the
part that's that I've always believed is
people are interested in the process
they're a lot smarter than what
marketers thought they want to know
about the details they want to know why
certain decisions were made they want to
you know they want to see what what were
the the routes that were taken and the
routes that were abandoned and they want
now they even want to experience this
for themselves so we're really in front
of an engaged you know consumer and that
means engagement means I want to touch
it I wanna do it myself
design now is it's one of the major
components at times would you say that's
even driving the the ship that is that
it's involved with these businesses I
mean we're so there's so many things
that are thrown at you you know apps and
products and and new concepts what's
gonna make you stick around you know
what's gonna make me stick around what's
gonna make me feel like I belong here I
want to stay here for a while
it's gonna have to be great the
experience the you know the way things
look the way things feel the way things
are engaging the way things are
simplified rather than complex that's
gonna keep me and and and all the other
people from you know to to to stick
around to enjoy this particular place
you know that can be a brand a product
an app an environment so if you were
talking to someone who would say they're
17 years old they're just getting ready
to start looking at college mm-hmm what
would you tell them where would what
would what should they start doing next
I think it's much as you know possible a
variety of experiences is still what
would I would
that said you know the tools are so
easily you can acquire them so easily
that you know experiencing things like
you know building things on a you know
on a on the computer and and growing
them you know it at school or at home
and I mean really getting into the
process learning you know by watching
others watching videos and others but
also learning by doing is something that
I think has been lost a little bit I
mean we we are you know of I think I
think in America there's it's now two
generations that I haven't had shop you
know by doing building things on the
computer yeah is like shop is like
experiencing the physical world
experiencing how you can shape it and
transform it and I think it's very
exciting that people are getting back to
doing it's it's it's it's gonna change
you know the sort of the sort of outlook
and possibly you know just how how this
society you know evolves in the next few
years